I did the world's first brain surgery in
a bear in the rainforest using a
mattress pump in an emergency to
complete the operation I've anesthetized
hundreds of seals many of which have
tried to commit suicide under anesthesia
and I did the world's first Keyhole
pendix removal in a sick wild orangutan
I'm romaine pizzi and I'm a Wildlife
veterinarian a Romaine has given us
unique access to terabyte's worth of his
own self shot footage here we'll be
covering three different surgeries
not only were we having to perform the
first brain surgery in a bear but it was
also in a jungle in a very undeveloped
country and having to fit everything we
could possibly need in two suitcases
temper was a rescued moon bear in Lao
that was confiscated as a tiny cab now
she had quite a swollen head but she was
behaving normally when she was Tiny But
as she got older rescue workers started
to suspect there was something wrong
with her brain she stopped being able to
see she started to have a lot of mucus
draining from her nose and she moved
very very slowly and that's when they
contacted me remains thought jumper
might have hydrocephalus a condition
where fluid builds up inside the skull
crushing the brain now there's no MRI in
the whole country when we had this case
so we had to figure out a different way
to do this so 9 000 kilometers away in
Scotland Romaine had to get creative
I've got a bear skull and actually took
a trace of it so I could play and where
would be the closest place that I would
be able to access her brain so I poured
some latex in the inside and made a mold
of what the shape of the brain is and
then planned on the computer how I would
approach the brain if this was water in
the brain hydrocephalus probably the
biggest challenge of the whole Endeavor
is flying to the other side of the world
to do brain surgery without knowing if
you've actually got the diagnosis right
his first step was anesthetizing jumper
and even that can have catastrophic
results too high a dose could be fatal
for Champa too little could be fatal for
remain I have had a bare wake up with me
in one occasion when I was operating and
I wasn't finished yet and it started to
shrug itself on the table and that's can
be quite a scary incidence when you have
150 kilogram really quite dangerous
animal waking up and you're not finished
suturing now Lao is obviously a very
underdeveloped country with limited
facilities even for human health care
we're not going to be able to get a vein
and put a little catheter in as you
could do in a pit or a human patient we
need to diet our patient so the safest
place to data bear is in the hand
muscles so the back leg and the top of
the leg basically it's bum with tamper
darted and asleep remain drilled a tiny
hole into her skull and the diagnosis
was correct hydrocephalus hydrocephalus
is a common condition in human children
and easily treated by draining the
excess fluid down to the abdomen using a
tube the body then absorbs the fluid but
obviously a bear is not like a child and
will climb trees and rub itself and has
sharp claws sharp claws that could rip
the tube out catastrophically the brain
could either collapse on itself or the
shunt could actually block so we buried
this little shunt just behind the base
of the ear so it wouldn't be able to get
its claws there we could make a very big
incision and put the tube in but then
the bay would risk opening this so we
want to do everything by Keyhole surgery
Keyhole surgery is where we use
specialized very thin instruments so
that we only end up with tiny surgical
wounds and we use a special surgical
telescope to be able to see inside the
body while we do it now the anatomy of a
base color is really different because
they have a big sinus on the top of
their head that's a big Airfield space
so where you'd put your tube in an
infant wouldn't work in a bit because it
would disappear into the sinus on top of
the head and so we actually had to drill
a little hole much further back with the
whole drilled and the shunt run down to
champa's abdomen the team were on the
home stretch until the electricity went
out so we borrowed a mattress pump and
what we did is ran that in very short
bursts just to put room air into the
abdomen just to give us enough space to
do the last bit of the operation which
we did very quickly just to make sure
that we don't put too much pressure left
this is an ingenious retractor which is
only five millimeters and we can stick
down the little tubes that can go safely
in the abdomen and then by turning the
handle it will turn into the surgical
equivalent of a keyhole surgery hand the
surgery took six hours the next morning
remain went down to champa's den after
years of pain and eyesight problems
Champa woke up and started to look at
remain and the team in the eyes the
surgery was a success
every year all over Europe many orphaned
gray and harbor seal pups need rescuing
and hand rearing and then they return to
the world now one of the most common
problems that I see as a surgeon is
actually seals with a ruptured eye the
eye beneath the tasked hundreds of seals
but they're still a really challenging
patient because they actually try to
commit suicide under anesthesia which is
a bit nerve-wracking and quite
frustrating
because seals live in water we describe
them as having something called a dive
reflex if you hold your breath for a
prolonged period of time you'll feel
that you need to take a breath you
cannot make yourself unconscious by
holding your breath as soon as you're
going to lose Consciousness you will
actually your brain will make you take a
breath now that doesn't work with seals
because if you're diving underwater and
you feel like you're building up carbon
Dax order running low on oxygen the
worst thing you can do is take a breath
because you'll drown so they have a
whole range of different adaptations
that their body uses to try and get
around this it slows their heart down
and it changes the blood flow through
different blood vessels it'll dilate the
blood vessels to the heart and the brain
and the kidneys those vital organs but
it will constrict blood vessels to other
non-vital organs now the problem is
under anesthesia can be difficult to
recognize and understand what's
happening and the seal might go into
these dive reflexes and as we try and
wake it up and it runs a little bit low
in oxygen and a bit higher in carbon
dioxide it actually slows its heart down
and circulates worth and it dies and so
these are things that we have to be very
aware of with how we anethe tar seals
and how we monitor them during
anesthesia the simplest solution to
preventing this whole dive reflex is to
actually breathe really well for our
seals and all we need to do is regularly
squeeze the Ambu bag that we're using to
give oxygen an anesthetic gases to our
patient regularly throughout the
anesthesia and that will prevent any of
these reflexes from happening but the
seal safely sedated remain must remove
the ruptured eye once you take the
eyeball out what could happen is their
skin can heal down into the socket and
it will end up with a little cavity now
that could accumulate little sea
creatures and all sorts of debris if
that animal goes back to the Wild and we
can't let that happen so to solve that
once we've taken the eyeball out and
before we close the skin we make a mesh
of stitches across that orbit so that
when the skin starts to sink down it
hits that mesh now I can use the thermal
camera to judge how the eyes healing and
to tell if there's any infection because
the blubber heals very differently so
this is what my eye would look like now
you'll actually see that my glasses will
reflect infrared from the light but a
seal's eye can look quite different
especially if there's an injury around
the eye or the eye has been partly
punctured it'll radiate a lot less heat
because it's actually a smaller
structure but I also have to be really
careful on how I suture this closed so
that it's watertight very soon and the
seal can go back into water a day or two
after its operation
so miria was a very specific case she'd
been confiscated from a farmer because
she'd been raiding his fruit trees and
he put her in a wooden crate and kept it
like that for two years so she'd gone to
one of the rescue centers and she was
doing really well when she suddenly got
very severely ill so they rushed her
into the clinic and took some X-rays and
this is when they saw the nail this was
a large metal nail and no one could
figure out where it was it looked like
it might be just up her bottom and she
was going to poo it out but then nail
never passed and that's when I got
involved now orangutans have quite a
long appendix a lot longer than ours and
little heavy things like stones and in
this case the nail will typically get
lodged there and they can cause a
problem an appendicitis and either
puncture the appendix or appendix can
rupture so now we know what the problem
is but our challenge is how to do
surgery so it doesn't turn into a
disaster because orangutans are probably
the most intelligent of all the gray
tapes and that's really interesting
although we may be more closely related
to chimpanzees chimpanzees learn in a
group with orangutans limo on their own
and so the youngsters will spend much
longer with their mom learning all the
life skills they have a very problem
solving way of thinking about the world
but when I do surgery anyone else does
something like it and they've got a
little bit of discomfort their first
inclination is to open any wound and try
and explore that now that can be an
absolute disaster if you open up the
abdomen because if they open the wound
and play with the intestines that will
be fatal and that's why Keyhole surgery
is so vital in orangutans to make the
tiny incisions that we're going to stick
our Keyhole surgery instruments through
really Texas one's eyesight and that's
why I use magnifying Loops to have a
look at what I'm doing and that just
allows me to see and keep sterile
without having my face right against the
orangutan the tiny area that I'm working
in orangutan's appendix surgery is the
same as human appendix surgery but
Romaine has to use even smaller
incisions in miria's case in her
orangutan because she's so clever and we
were worried she'd open those holes I
used even smaller instruments so these
are even just three millimeters in
diameter barely larger than a microchip
needle and those tiny holes don't even
really need stitches and there's no
chance that she'd be able to open them
or even poke a grass blade inside to
interfere with the operation after I'm
finished now miria had a really good
outcome she recovered really quickly she
almost didn't notice she'd had surgery
because those wounds were so tiny she
was eating an hour after she woke up a
couple of months later when they were
preparing to get her ready to go back to
the wild they actually managed to foster
a small baby onto her and she was great
and she took this little baby and looked
after it and started to teach her things
and when they released miria back to the
forest she took the baby with her and
they've been monitoring her the last few
years and it's almost five years now
that she and her now quite large infant
that she's adopted are doing doing
really well so that is something really
deeply satisfying that the operation
actually resulted in such a happy
outcome